Let me guess, you've got some downtime and are scrolling through Facebook,...
...liking everyone's photos but you're not commenting.
What if I told you Facebook likes could be turning you into an idiot?
That's according to new research so don't shoot the messenger.
Likes are dumbing down the way people communicate with each other...
...and stop us from responding intelligently, according to Salon.
The digital era overload brings on thoughtless commentary...
...in the form of likes and reactions.
Experts say having so many channels of communication...
...makes for cheap and easy forms of interaction that doesn't require much thought.
But some people are drawn to that sound and the likes they collect.
Studies have shown the instant gratification of seeing how many people liked your post...
...has a neurological effect similar to how we feel when eating something good,...
...after working out, or when we're in the bedroom.
That's according to Psychology Today.
And don't lie, you know you get excited when your post gets a lot of likes.
Still, experts say that tiny affirmations don't substitute for meaningful conversation.
Instead, they recommend keeping a core social media group...
...who provide thoughtful feedback.